bienvenue à tous pour ce nouveau numéro
de Paris Saclay le mag au sommaire de
cette nouvelle édition l'inauguration de
la cité de l'innovation Alcatel Lucin a
choisi nausée pour implanter le premier
centre en Europe dédié à l'innovation
ouverte un centre qui inventera les
réseaux de demain on vous emmène aussi
au 503 ce site est bien plus qu'un
Institut d'Optique ouvert sur le monde
extérieur il propose aux étudiants un
écosystème favorable à l'innovation et à
la recherche il les plonge au cœur de
l'entrepreneuriat nous verrons comment
Paris Saclay c'est aussi une future
université elle n'est pas encore achevée
mais elle se dévoile petit à petit le
grand public a pu le constater lors de
la dernière édition de la Fête de la
Science à Gif-sur-Yvette et nous
resterons à Gif-sur-Yvette pour un
festival original qui donne la parole
aux traducteur VOVF se déroule dans un
cadre enchanteur le Moulin de la
tuilerie ancienne demeure des Windsor
enfin à ne pas rater toutes les
rendez-vous de ce mois de novembre c'est
dans notre agenda à la fin de cette
émission
tout un symbole Alcatel Lucens a choisi
nausée pour implanter sa cité de
l'innovation qui regroupe 5000 personnes
sur 36 hectares le groupe il y a
implanté la plus grande plateforme
européenne de tests de réseau mobile un
lieu aux aires de campus américain ou ce
côtoie chercheur start-up et étudiant un
seul mot d'ordre innové écoutez les
précisions de Fatima bacthi c'est la
directrice du projet
l'ensemble ici sur le site de villarso
d'Alcatel USA que nous nous montrent dès
à présent cité de l'innovation qui est
localisé sur la commune de Nozay depuis
18 mois nous avons opéré une
transformation au sein du groupe et dans
le cas de cette transformation nous
avons regroupé l'ensemble des sites de
la région parisienne sur le site de
Villarceau nous sommes maintenant plus
de 4000 salariés sur ce site alors nous
faisons un lancement parce que bien
évidemment nous avons fait beaucoup de
choses beaucoup de travaux mais il en
reste encore à faire donc ce lancement
c'est la dynamique vers le campus de la
cité de l'innovation un campus ouvert
nous avons l'ensemble des métiers
d'Alcatel Hussin présent sur le site
nous avons une force de frappe énorme
sur le développement
nous y faisons donc recherche
développement et livraison à nos clients
de produits télécoms
très concrètement nous développons ici
des Smalls les Smalls ce sont les
petites cellules au niveau de la radio
de telle sorte à développer des systèmes
qui permettent à chacun d'entre nous de
pouvoir
communiquer de pouvoir être connecté
avec son mobile ou qu'il soit dans la
cité et dans la ville et bien pour cela
nous développons les produits qui sont
utiles pour avoir une cette connectivité
c'est un exemple
mais de développons tous les systèmes au
niveau radio nous avons eu des plus
grandes plateformes européennes de tests
de mobiles et de réseaux mobiles en
Europe
nous nous inscrivons en fait dans la
démarche du plateau de sacré
nous sommes en collaboration avec la FCS
et bien sûr avec le PPS avec lequel nous
avons de bonnes relations et avec
lesquels nous travaillons
nous avons vraiment vocation à mettre en
contact des startups et les bellabs et
les centres de développement et les
plateformes de telle sorte à ce que
l'innovation croise et que l'on puisse
tous ensemble innover
nous voici au 503 autre lieu innovants
de Paris Saclay il est situé dans un
bâtiment historique celui de l'Institut
d'Optique ici on trouve des chercheurs
des étudiants et des startups le 503 se
veut un écosystème favorable à
l'innovation et à la recherche
collaborative des entrepreneurs viennent
ici pour épauler la nouvelle génération
il donne des conseils à ses étudiants
les coachs pour les rendre les plus
performants possibles une méthode qui
donne déjà des résultats regardez
nous sommes ici donc au 5003 qui est le
centre d'entrepreneuriat de l'Institut
d'Optique graduerschool dans lequel on
développe des programmes en faveur de
l'entrepreneuriat de la stimulation de
l'entrepreneuriat et d'innovation chez
des jeunes particulièrement donc des
étudiants entrepreneurs et qu'on plonge
dans un écosystème composé de start-up
technologiques innovantes pour ces
jeunes entrepreneurs ces startups jouent
un petit peu le rôle de grand frère les
coachs les accompagnent leur donnent des
conseils donc ils peuvent les rencontrer
et avoir des modèles de développement
je dirige une société qui s'appelle
thématis notre société a des locaux ici
pour pour plusieurs raisons c'est
d'abord c'est que je donne quelques
cours de marketing des technologies à
l'Institut d'optique et le fait d'être
présent d'être sur place nous facilite
les choses mais nous a permis par
exemple d'embaucher une jeune fille il y
a deux ans qui vient de la philosophique
vous avez des ressources clés dans dans
ce lieu il y a notamment des salles
mutualisées dédiées à la créativité à
l'organisation de forums de conférences
où se retrouvent les étudiants
entrepreneurs des experts qui viennent
justement aider ces étudiants
il y a également un photonique FabLab
qui permet de mutualiser des ressources
technologiques et qui est ouvert aux
étudiants entrepreneurs et aux
entreprises en développement
je t'ai diplômé de SupOptique en 2010 où
j'ai suivi les rénovation entrepreneurs
à la suite de quoi pendant deux ans j'ai
travaillé à l'étranger et puis on a
monté notre boîte être au bâtiment 503
ça nous permet de vivre dans un
écosystème où il y a mais beaucoup de
gens dans le domaine de l'optique donc
c'est assez facile de discuter avec des
experts en plus de quoi on a également
accès aux FabLab ce qui nous aide
beaucoup dans notre développement
prototype
le 503 est un des lieux innovants du
Campus Paris Saclay et qui a l'ambition
d'assurer des connexions entre les
différents publics et personnes qui
vivent sur ce campus donc entre les
chercheurs les industries les startups
et les étudiants dans l'objectif de
favoriser l'entrepreneuriat la création
d'entreprises la valorisation de la
recherche
cet appareil sacré que se développe la
plus grande université de recherche
d'Europe continentale sont déjà présents
12.000 enseignants et chercheurs 60 000
étudiants sont attendus à terme le grand
public a pu suivre l'avancée du projet
lors de la dernière édition de la Fête
de la Science Agif sur Yvette depuis des
années c'est l'association
île de sciences qui est aux manettes
écoutez les précisions de leur Reinhardt
président de l'association
île de sciences et de Dominique Vernet
c'est le président de la fondation de
coopération scientifique Campus Paris
Saclay
vous êtes ici dans le gymnase de
Gif-sur-Yvette à la Fête de la Science
organisée depuis plusieurs années par
île de sciences nous regroupons dans le
cadre de cette fête de la science
l'ensemble des acteurs recherche
enseignement supérieur du plateau de
Saclay et de ses environs l'objectif
étant de se mettre à la portée des
différents publics puisque nous recevons
des enfants
nous recevons des adolescents nous
recevons des jeunes adultes mais aussi
des chercheurs qui ont effectivement
envie de partager avec leur collègues
différents types de résultats
l'Université du plateau de Saint-Clair
et pas encore complètement finalisé vous
voyez derrière moi un certain nombre de
ballons et de représentation graphiques
qui montrent que cet université est très
présente et presque créée
dès le démarrage d'île de sciences il y
a une trentaine d'années nous avions
comme objectif de réunir l'ensemble des
utilisateurs du plateau de Saclay et je
suis particulièrement fière de présider
cette association qui finalement donne
lieu aujourd'hui à cette belle
réalisation qui est l'université
Paris-Saclay
l'Université Paris sacré quelques
nombres c'est 19 établissements
d'enseignement supérieur de recherche et
d'organismes qui travaillent qui ont
décidé de travailler ensemble de porter
la bannière une bannière commune pour en
fait être reconnu international c'est
aussi
12000 chercheurs et enseignants
chercheurs c'est 60000 étudiants dont
40% de doctorants et
d'étudiants au niveau master donc cette
université paris-saclet ça va être une
grande université de recherche en fait
ça sera la plus importante en Europe
continentale et l'objectif est bien
c'est d'être visible mondialement
puisqu'on est dans l'air de la
mondialisation et bien la compétition
sur la sur la connaissance c'est aussi
une compétition importante et dans
lequel on considère qu'on a tous les
atouts sous réserve qu'on travaille
ensemble
au reste à Gif-sur-Yvette pour un
festival bucolique et littéraire VOVF
comprenez version originale version
française nous propose de rencontrer nos
pas les auteurs de livres de romans
d'essai mais leur traducteur des hommes
et des femmes qui passent plusieurs mois
sur un nouveau ouvrage ce festival
original se déroule dans un cadre
enchanteur le Moulin de la tuilerie
ancienne demeure des Windsor nous avons
rencontré Pierre Maurice co-organisateur
de l'événement
ce festival c'est donc là c'est la
deuxième édition l'idée c'est d'inviter
les traducteurs à parler des livres
qu'ils ont traduit et c'est toujours
passionnant parce que même quand on est
un grand lecteur on lit beaucoup mais la
contrepartie c'est qu'on lit vite un
traducteur lui va passer six mois un an
sur un livre à travailler sur ce livre
et donc c'est toujours passionnant
d'entendre parler de ce livre il va se
poser des questions que nous on se pose
pas il va aller au coeur du texte il va
se demander comment le livre est
construit pourquoi telle personnage
s'appelle comme ça il va chercher des
références et tout ça il va essayer de
le mettre dans sa traduction donc c'est
un des meilleurs connaisseurs de
du livre de l'auteur de cette
littérature
l'idée c'est vraiment de parler des
livres et c'est pour ça qu'on en fait un
rendez-vous annuel c'est parce que des
livres des chefs-d'oeuvre des livres
dont il est nécessaire important
intéressant de parler il y en a tous les
ans qui sortent et les auteurs à
découvrir partout
c'est le sujet c'était la traduction on
aurait pu pour le grand public voilà
épuiser le sujet assez vite et se lancer
dans des querelles de spécialistes là
vraiment l'idée c'est de parler des
livres c'est les traducteurs qui vous
donnent envie parce qu'ils connaissent
bien auteur parce qu'ils connaissent
bien au roman qui vous donne envie de
d'ouvrir le livre
c'est un festival ouvert à tout le monde
c'est le grand public que l'on veut tous
les types de lecteurs c'est pour ça
qu'on parle des romans des romans du
monde entier de l'arabe du catalan
des romans du Maghreb l'Amérique les
gens qui lisent de la poésie qui lisent
des policiers la littérature jeunesse de
la littérature de l'imaginaire
c'est un cadre enchanteur donc
historique parce que c'est la demeure du
Duc et de Duchesse de Louisor et donc il
y a déjà ce
passé
franco-anglais voilà qui était
intéressant
place maintenant à notre agenda à ne pas
rater en ce mois de novembre
l'exposition Paris Saclay le futur en
chantier avec un sa chantier évidemment
au vu du défi relevé ça se passe à la
Maison de l'architecture à Paris dans le
10e arrondissement cette exposition
gratuite est ouverte au grand public
vous pourrez suivre des tableaux rondes
des conférences ce sera les 28 29 et 30
novembre autre temps fort l'Open comput
project Rupert subite premier édition un
événement organisé par la Fondation Open
Compute qui a été créée par facebook on
y trouve des grands noms comme Intel IBM
Microsoft ce rendez-vous a permis de
découvrir les dernières tendances
technologiques conçues par la communauté
OPC présente aux USA et en Asie
principalement la Fondation a décidé de
lancer officiellement son activité en
Europe au mois d'octobre elle a choisi
Paris Saclay pour ça première édition
nous y reviendrons évidemment et puis
n'oublions pas le Smart manufacturing
paris-saclet conférences événements qui
réunira les leaders de l'automobile que
l'aéronautique de l'énergie de la
sécurité et de la ville intelligente au
cœur des débats l'usine du futur ou
comment réinventer l'industrie de 2020
ce sera le 28 novembre au Palais des
Congrès de Versailles et voilà c'est
déjà la fin de cette émission merci de
votre attention se retrouve très vite
pour un nouveau numéro de Paris-Saclay
le mag d'ici là pour rester informés une
seule adresse epps.fr à très bientôt